Ngày 20, tổng thư kỳ đảng phíau thái, kiếm bộ trường rù lịch khái Lan, ông Sodor Wong, Thien Thông, Trò biết,
thủ tưởng Tét Tổng tàn Sinowatra sẽ không tự chất,
hãy giải tàn của hội sau vụ giò gì để đàn với chủ tịch thưởng viện gặp buồn chia, ông Sodor Wong,
khẳng định mà phía tổng tàn gặp kết tiếp tục giải quyết các cuộc khủng hảng hiện nay,
bao gồm gặp thẳng biên dợi với cà buồn chia, chính xác thế quan từ Mỹ,
trên áp buồn và mặt tủ ý tổng tạng và thúc đẩy ngành rù lịch.
Thủ tưởng Petong Tàn, lấy năm cuyên từ tháng chiến năm 2020, sau khi lập lên mình mấy mộ đảng gió phíau thái dẫn đó,
chính phủ của bà đã đối mắt vỡ sức ổ sau khi đoạn đi âm cuộc liện đàn cả nhân,
giữa bà về ông Hun Sẽnh bị giò gì trong đó bà gọi chủ tịch thưởng viện gặp buồn chia là chú,
đồng thời chế chắc một số tưởng liện quân đội thái Lan.
Bà Petong Tàn thừa nhật tích sắc thực của đoạn đi âm và xí lỗi công trúng,
nhưng khẳng định đầy chỉ là một chiến thật đàn phán, tổng anh hưởng đến phóan hệ với quân đội.
Fia cảm ủ tiê cũng sát nhận một qua trước nừng này đã làm lộ và giám,
giò có bất mãn trước việc ông Hun Sẽnh và con trời khuyên mà nét khục đổn trọng.
Phà nướng trước bà giám ngày mấy tạng hằng sau, đảng buồn gia thái,
lối tác lần thứ 2 trong lý mình cảm quyền tuyên bộ giúp phó chính phủ sau biểu bối,
trong khi phay đối lập giá tăng kia vỏ thủ tưởng tự chất,
quyền yên hai đảng dân chủ và chào thái phát tăng á đã tin bố tiếp tục ông Hộ chính phủ.
Zúb Linh mình vẫn giữ lập thế đã số tại hà viện.
Nếu thêm bất kỳ đối tác nở giúp lôi,
chính phủ thái lan hiện có thể xúc lâu, kéo theo cuộc mâu cử mới.